hi I'm Andrew Stein rocker and I'm with
WolframAlpha and I'm going to be talking
about food and nutrition in the Wolfram
language including a lot of the new
ingredient substitutions and packaged
food data that we have available
I'm gonna be talking about food and
nutrition my foot Brandon's name on here
- he's the other lead developer on this
project and let's get started so first
thing I want to do when we get in is I
want to give you a brief overview of
what we have available in the language I
intend to try and make it pretty brief
because there's a lot of information
there I'll show you more information
about that on a future slide but I'm
really trying to show off or show you
some of the improvements that we have
made to existing stuff as well as a lot
of the new things that we've hooked up
to as I had mentioned I've done this
talk or talks just like this in the past
two years and I've tried to compile as
much of the information as I can into
this one slide here so please download
the notebook it's unpassable there's
lots of other information that I can't
show in the amount of time that's here
but please feel free to download the
notebook it's unpassable and all the
information that you may need to know is
here as well as well so to give you a
whirlwind intro to the food and
nutrition information in the language we
have of information on about 150,000
foods now spread over about 150
nutrients we can do things like make
nutrition labels for example and we also
have detailed information on like fatty
acids for example so in order to keep
track of a lot of this stuff we have to
have a system to classify and represent
various kinds of foods and so we have a
growing set of over 10,000 attributes
spread over nearly 50 categories and so
that allows us to handle a lot of
different kinds of foods like raw foods
and fruits and things like that as well
as packaged foods and so here's just
some of the examples of the categories
and some examples of the specific
attributes that we have we also have a
lot of physical information on over a
thousand food types that are interns and
internal curation team have curated
including images inside-outside colors
and approximate shapes as well as their
dimensions and some of the cool things
you can do with that data as I've shown
before in previous talks um you can you
can find say vegetables with wider cream
interiors weighted by their iron content
make a nice some image collage out of it
that way as an example some of the other
things we support too is on
natural language processing and so if we
if you type in say Red Delicious apple
we know how to classify that using our
implicit entity syntax as you can see
here the neat thing about this too is
it's also smarter about things like
brand names so for example if you put in
Big Mac we know that it's a burger and
you know Pepsi we know they make drinks
so that information is built in so that
way you can say food in the way that you
would typically say maybe in a web form
or something as I've shown before and of
course we also support a food type
interpreter as well and it's sort of a
fuzzier way to sort of think of things
how you can more broadly look at things
rather than capturing all the details in
one shot so that's sort of a brief
overview of what we have available in
the language that's sort of the core
functionality of it now we can start
talking about some of the improved
things and one of the things we've been
improving over the past couple years is
adding more and more foods so we've been
adding about fifty thousand foods every
year and so now we're looking at almost
about 150 thousand foods which is which
is getting to be pretty large and very
nice and pretty comprehensive I think
I'm going a little deeper into the
improvements we've made one of the big
improvements that we made with involving
colors we have these sets of curated
colors but one of the problems we ran
into with these is that it's difficult
to know which colors say the most common
color we knew that we had curated the
apples for example were red green or
yellow but the problem was is that when
we want when you go use it in an
application you may um not know which
color to use for example like this one
down here where I've made a a word cloud
where I've waited them by vitamin A but
I also want them to be colored according
to their most common outside color it's
really difficult unless you have this
property so you can just pull out one
one color rather than a list of them and
attempt to guess which color it's
supposed to be so again we also have
this on the outside colors as well as
the inside colors for example another
improvement we made involve barcodes and
I had shown in my first talk in 2015
that we can you can do lookups based on
barcodes and set up a barcode scanner
just by taking an image and using
barcode recognized
we've improved this a little
so that you don't have to include a
check digit so here it's you can kind of
see it here where I've left off the one
at the end here and so I've given it one
less digit than it needs but our our
stuff actually computes that check digit
and puts it in there so you can hunt
through those without much trouble
another improvement we made with
barcodes is supporting g10 which is the
global trade identification number and
it's basically a superset of the typical
UPC's that you see that are usually
twelve digits long Deaton's can be eight
I think eleven twelve and thirteen and
fourteen digits long and so for example
we can support it here with this one
which gives an eight digit one as well
as you can use barcode image to create
your own barcodes out of it as well
another improvement we made was with a
visualization property that we
introduced called compass plot which
sort of gives a nice visual way to
represent how much food your nutrition
intake and how it relates to say
limitations basically if it's like your
daily values or other nutritional goals
we got a few complaints about how to
read it and not really understand it
they didn't really understand what what
it was and how to read it and so one way
to fix that as you can see is that we've
supported zooming in and changing the
scale so for the same food but just with
different amounts you can see that we've
now zoom in so the shape is still
visible at basically every scale you can
think of just about well but the scale
changes and we've introduced a legend to
also see that too and so you can kind of
see in the old ones which I've put up
here that when you get to really large
limits like in the tolerable upper
intake level um it's really it's very
kind of tiny it's you know a handful of
pixels down there you really have to
squint and look at with the new system
you don't have to because the scales
change appropriately so that you can see
the overall shape of it another
improvement that we made last year was
that we introduced over 25,000
international foods from 20 countries or
so and so we've introduced that stuff
and to give you a brief review these
were tagged up with a language thesaurus
which has over 7,000 detailed terms for
all sorts of things and they're
translated into several different
languages which is very convenient when
working with foods that come from other
countries and things like that and so
these are these foods were tagged up as
I mentioned by um compilers and they
manually go through and curate which
tags go with which foods and that sort
of thing and we support lookups with
those using implicit entity syntax as a
in this example that I showed last year
where you can find say cheese's by going
through and picking out some language
previously up until now that was really
the only way you could go through these
was you'd have to know the the thesaurus
and know which terms you were looking
for and create your query from there and
search through them that way but after
some alignment effort now you don't have
to do that instead we've gone through
and set up the alignment so that you can
just use our typical attributes that we
have already food types and those sorts
of things just to search through them so
here for example I'm using the fishes
food type group to be able to grab all
kinds of fish in the European data that
we have available going a little further
with the international route one thing
that is supported internationally in
grocery stores and other things are
price lookup codes or PLU codes as
people typically recognize them and
they're the four digit codes that you
see on produce and things like that
little stickers on apples and things
like that that you may see in a grocery
store and there's a lot of information
that goes with these because they need
to be able to grocery stores need to
maintain prices and inventory and that
sort of thing for you know maybe
hundreds of varieties of foods fruits
and vegetables for example and so we
have a lot of that information included
and attached to these entities now
including the count size which is what
we use in the u.s. al-ma to measure the
size based on how many fit in a standard
container whereas in the rest of the
world you may use a mass or a diameter
as you can see here so going a little
deeper with these PLU codes on my
mentioned before with barcode scanning
things you can write a little bit of
Wolfram language code to be able to do a
similar thing with PLU codes where I've
just used barcode recognizer here on a
little bit of code to manipulate the
string that comes back to pull off the
peel peel you code that's needed and
then also sort of use the entity
framework to be able to pick out how we
would represent that using our implicit
entity syntax so you can see here that
40 53 goes with lemons and 41:31 goes
with food
apples another new feature that we
introduced was with pH information so
it's sometimes nice to know this
information at the food type level so we
have four food types we have PHS and you
can sort through these things and search
through them using implicit entity
syntax so here for example like you can
find basic foods just by using greater
than or you can find acidic foods using
less equal than for example and you can
also use between to find maybe save sort
of neutral foods and in a particular
range or you can also use take largest
and take smallest to find the extreme
values and those sorts of things these
values have been aggregated over more
detailed information that comes from our
data source and so you can see some
sometimes there's some variation between
different kinds like here from different
varieties of apples they vary a little
bit it's also nice to see and and group
things on more of a food type group
levels so you can sort of zoom out and
see things in bigger bigger clumps of
foods that way so that's kind of a nice
use of number line plot to see that
going a little further one of the other
big things we introduced last year was
packaged food ingredients and we had
tens of thousands of foods I don't
remember exactly how many we had but we
have quite a few more now and now we
have about a hundred thousand packaged
foods in our database now and we have
all kinds of information that you would
find on a package including marketing
descriptions as well as these warning
labels and ingredient lists that you can
see here and a lot of these have very
useful information like for example
allergens and things like that and if
you you know have a dietary restriction
or an allergy or something these lists
are very handy to go through and find
out what foods you can and can't eat but
the problem with these is that they come
back to us as raw strings and there's a
lot of problems with that because
they're not really computable or not
very easily computable a lot of times
they come in as capital letters and so
they're not really all that friendly to
look at because it looks like someone's
screaming at you basically but and so
it's not really nice looking also
there's a hierarchical structure to
these things and so they're a little
difficult to work with if you want to
actually find out what ingredients are
made of other ingredients and those
sorts of things
so if you want to find maybe the high
level ingredients you'd have to do a lot
of
processing to rip out parentheses and
things like that to go dig through those
but most importantly lookups are really
difficult because you'd have to do some
kind of string matching and that sort of
thing and that becomes very difficult
very quickly so the solution to that is
that we've done it for you already and
introduced our own ingredient entities
so appears just an example of some of
the food ingredient entities you can see
here we have a list of a little less
than 5,000 and we're growing in size as
we go along and so for example with the
simple property call you can just get
back a list of these computable
ingredient entities rather than this big
string here and one thing to note about
these entities is that they come back
and we've tried to keep the order as
close as possible to what's in the given
in the actual string there - some
duplicates and things like that because
the order is pretty important because
the the first listed ingredients are
much more have there's much more of
those ingredients than there are in
subsequent ingredients so the order is
pretty important with those and there
are other properties that we have as
well which you'll see shortly but the
important thing is that um you can use
the implicit entity syntax to be able to
search through these foods pretty easily
so for example if you want to find foods
that have a certain ingredient on them
you can search through them that way and
of course you can use the contains
family of functions to be able to find
those that match a certain criteria
maybe like this one where you might be
looking for ingredients that list both
rice and beer or maybe use contains none
to say find beans that don't have salt
listed as an ingredient of course as I
mentioned before if you're trying to do
some of that string processing work to
try and figure out which ingredients are
made of other ingredients we've taken
some of that into consideration already
using this property that which we call
main ingredients which basically removes
the parentheses and takes out anything
after a statement like contains less
than 2% of and so you can do queries on
those for example here and so that sort
of gives a simplified list of
ingredients to work with
additionally we also give access to the
first listed ingredient which I
mentioned before is the one that's the
most prevalent or predominant and lastly
we also have a property for looking at
ingredient counts
that way you can search for foods that
have less than a certain number or
something like that - and like a like I
mentioned before on the other slide with
the all the contains family of functions
works on these as well so you can dig
through and search through foods that
way so that solves the lookup problem
but it's a little a little more
difficult if you want to use use it for
if you have say an allergy or something
like that and so we've introduced
entities for that as well to make it
much easier to sort through we've
introduced these dietary restriction
entities and you can see a list of them
here and we have curated lists of food
types and ingredients that you can avoid
for all of these things just given in
these properties here as you can see the
neat thing about this is that we give
multiple lists of levels of confidence
basically if you want to think of it
that way for example we have compatible
ones which are certainly allowed
incompatible ones which are definitely
not allowed and then sort of
questionable lists which are sort of
gray areas where you may have to dig
deeper and look into with all these
things and we have all this information
as well down at the food level as well
so for example you can use this to look
for lutein free foods that we have or
foods that are certainly not gluten free
as well again sometimes we get a lot of
questions about you know the differences
between the dietary restrictions and
things like that so we've also
introduced a description property that
gives sort of a nice textual description
of what these things are and why you may
do them and that sort of thing
another issue that people get confused
on how these all relate so we've also
introduced an implied dietary
restrictions property that allows you to
say that you know if a food is gluten
free then it's also wheat free if a food
is vegan it's also vegetarian and so on
and so forth another new feature that
we've introduced is with ingredient
substitutions we have a growing list of
about 2,000 ingredient substitutions and
it's it's growing and we're looking to
improve it so for example here I've just
put allspice as an example where you can
see with the implicit entity syntax we
have here you can replace it with ground
cinnamon ground cloves and ground nutmeg
but this might be a little bit difficult
to read so I think I've got
better solution for you here where I've
replaced them with images instead sort
of to integrate with the images that we
have baked into the system so you can
kind of see what these things are and
I've also included it with mouse overs
on them so you can see exactly what they
are before so right now um these are
written in terms of explicit quantities
and I believe Eric has a talk later in
the conference that it covers physical
quantities and things like that with
Michael and so we support all of these
and so you can convert these as you need
one of the features we do want to
support is you know giving these in
terms of typical imperial units like
maybe teaspoons and tablespoons but it's
it's a work in progress at the moment
we're getting we're getting there but we
also support other units too like for
example items so you can see here that
maybe an avocado leaf if you if you have
a recipe that calls for that you may
rather use two bay leaves instead to
replace it for example now these
explicit quantities are nice and
everything but sometimes you don't know
what you're what you're working with
what what exact numbers you're working
with so sometimes it's nicer to have
things in terms of ratios so by
eliminating the quantities in the
left-hand sides of these rules we can
sort of represent these on a more ratio
level so you can just multiply by a
factor to get whatever you need so for
example here on the ground allspice
example now we can see that forty
percent by volume you can get these two
and only six percent by volume will give
you that so that way you can scale it to
any quantity that you like that you
would like to have items are done in the
same way except the ratios are pretty
clear you know one to two ratio and so
on and so forth now to go another level
deeper you can see things on a more
qualitative level and so we can do that
by looking at the food types that we
have available to us so you can see
maybe you have a recipe that calls for
acai berry you might want to replace
them with blueberries or cranberries or
cherries for example or other things
like that and this also allows to do
reverse lookups using implicit entity
syntax and that means that you can um
say you know if I have a certain
ingredient what else can I use what can
be replaced by it so you can use use
to find a better better replacements
that way and maybe a fancier recipe
calls for something more interesting
that way lastly I guess I'll go ahead
and finish up by showing some of our
future goals soon we're going to be
updating the Wolfram Alpha a scanner
output and as well as the API that goes
with it and so here I've given a brief
screen shot to kind of show you some of
the work that we're doing there so that
will be happening hopefully soon in the
next couple weeks and then lastly some
more things that we really want to do in
the future here is cover-more food
nutrition for the rest of the world our
first target I think on what we want to
add next is probably Asian foods and
that sort of thing
we also are wanting to cover more
packaged foods and more data thats
related to them involving storage times
and temperatures as well as you know
packaging dimensions and the materials
that are used with them we'd also like
to align two ingredient entities our
ingredient entities - the ones that are
in chemical data I know Jason Biggs is
giving a talk about that in the future
we'd like to align to those entities as
well and another big project that we'd
like to do is handle FDA nutrition
labels with their differences of the
different sizes and shapes and those
sorts of things and then of course this
can all probably fit together into a
really nice computational recipe system
now that we have most of the pieces for
these including the nutrition and the
actions and equipment that I've shown
before as well as the new ingredient
substitutions that I've just shown here
and with that I will open it for
questions I guess
you mean the the out of the WolframAlpha
scanner well so when I'm referring to
the WolframAlpha scanner I mean if you
go to Wolfram Alpha comm and you type in
calories in a cheeseburger or something
like that that's the output that we're
updating right now it's it's not up to
date with most of the things that I've
shown on this talk but it will be soon
yes yes right
yeah yeah it's very similar yes oh
absolutely yeah and in fact it's very
similar to this one here yeah it's
actually very similar to this example
here where I'm using barcode recognizer
to read in the bar code that's written
on the the PLU codes it's just a
different barcode but yes we do support
that as far as in Wolfram Alpha I think
you for now you may have to type in the
numbers yourself and read it off the par
code but we will support that some time
hopefully soon yeah I can build you
something like that it's actually it's a
very simple query you're right it's it's
not that difficult to do so yeah yeah
that would be a good one I haven't done
that myself but yes that would be really
handy yeah yeah yes right that's true
yeah yeah yeah so as far as tutorials go
on this I think your best bet is gonna
be unfortunately at the moment to
download this notebook and take a look
at some of the information I have here
unfortunately the entity framework is
not super well documented in my
experience there is some documentation
about entity and entity property but
weird I think it's in the works to have
documentation on specific domains and
those sorts of things
oh it's unpassable
I can talk to you afterwards if you're
interested but it's on just on the
packaging yes right
yes--it's yeah
right yeah
exactly
yeah absolutely yeah I'd be more than
happy to talk about it yes yeah yes
exactly yes
Yeah right exactly so so the best of
your best bet is to write an API or a
form function in the cloud I think is
probably the best bet to do that which
which I've done before I can show you
how to do that if you're interested but
yeah I think you're right the best way
is to communicate over api's and those
sorts of things
hopefully not yeah not yet no it's it's
still I'm not pretty linear and going up
so right damn good I I don't know about
that but um I'm not so sure about that
but maybe yeah well I think it's pretty
much myself and Brandon are pretty much
the main developers I know Bjorn and
Michael helped a lot as well as two of
our interns are here now a lot of the
curation work is being done by them and
others in yes yes yeah there are food
science yes right yeah exactly right
um but yeah and and also our internal
curation team as well helps a lot so
although it's just Brandon I might as
lead developers on it so to speak um
there's a lot of help that we get from
from interns and the curation team and
everyone else so
that's that's a good question yeah
exactly yeah that's a good point yeah
exactly
I guess if there are no more questions
then I guess we'll stop here